Miller is prepared to make a significant
concession to the Trump legal team
citing sources John Roberts reporting
that Muller has agreed to reduce the
number of questions for president Trump
at a potential interview from his
initial list of 49 Muller is also
willing to accept some answers in
writing though he wants aural answers to
others
Trump attorney Rudy Giuliani responded
to the tug of war over an interview
earlier today they sent us a proposal we
responded to their proposal they took
about ten days and yesterday we got a
letter back from it and now we're in the
process of it they should render their
report I mean I guess going up joining
us now to analyze Alan Dershowitz author
of the book big bestseller the case
against impeaching Trump along with Saul
Weissenberg former deputy independent
counsel in the Whitewater investigation
all right professor Dershowitz what do
you make of this latest development
supposed concessions they don't seem
like huge concessions to me but
nevertheless down from 49 questions some
in writing does this change the calculus
I don't think so it's not about quantity
it's about quality all I have to do is
ask him one question what was your
motive why did you fire a Comey or why
did you ask Comey
maybe to go easy on Flynn all they want
to do is get him to say in a context
where he could be charged with a crime
something that's controversial and
something that somebody else will come
in and testify and say no he told me
something different no he told me that
his motive was this or that motives are
so vague and subjective and you can be
charged with lying to prosecution
officials even if you tell the truth if
there's another witness who comes in and
gives a different account and the
prosecutor is trying to get you and want
to put one to put you in a perjury trap
and believe so says he believes the
other witness who may not only be
singing but he may be composing in order
to get a better deal you've walked into
a perjury trap so in the end I don't
think his lawyers are gonna let
President
testify orally at all look the president
may get his way he says he wants to
testify but no lawyer is gonna walk his
client into a perjury trap tonight the
New York Times Saul is reporting that
the president is pushing for an
interview with Muller against the advice
of counsel now I don't know if this is
kind of a you know they're playing
around here on this and it's a good PR
or if that's the real deal but let's
pretend for the moment
that's real your reaction I think it's
suicidal I think it's it's idiotic I
agree with the professor here's here's
the real key here based on everything we
know they don't have anything close to
an obstruction case on the president but
it is much easier in addition to the
stuff that Professor Gershowitz said it
is much easier to prove a case of lying
to the government under 18 US Code
section thousand-and-one than it is to
prove an obstruction case particularly
based on what they have it has to be
material but the threshold for a
material lie is extremely low and their
cases are legion of convicting people
under a thousand and one including
Martha Stewart so it's a terrible
strategy and I can't believe me I would
physically restrain my client in these
circumstances you and I both yeah you
and I both okay